can you imagine the Harry Potter
franchise without Ginny Weasley yeah
it's pretty difficult to do but the
actor who played this iconic character
thinks Ginny deserved way more time on
screen Bonnie Wright recently appeared
on Michael rosenbaum's inside of you
podcast where she opened up about the
disappointment she felt as a result of
the material she was given to work with
when it came to Bringing Ginny Weasley
to life it's
[Music]
all just a memory Bonnie Wright wasn't
too pleased with the time on screen and
character development she got as Ginny
Weasley in the Harry Potter franchise
and she hasn't been shy about telling
the world how she feels there were parts
of the character that just didn't get to
come through because there weren't the
scenes to do that she explained maybe my
anxiety was about like oh I'm going to
be seen as like badly portraying this
character rather than later realizing I
wasn't really given the opportunity to
do that so it wasn't really my fault